hello and welcome enters video playing
semeta oh wait yeah he's the sky okay he
always places lying in the road and I
don't know and I have problems again so
I want to do something else this is T
for whatever I gambit line and this also
have I have no idea what I don't know
it's that good for me
I'm currently experimenting with this g
six month we takes it and so it's a nice
surprise ok I don't know to sell not to
have six let's go here I'm always happy
if they give me the bishop pair for no
particular compensation even though
white pieces are very ok so I mean it's
not like it's clearly were so anything
but if i have the bishop a at least i
know some have some idea what to what to
do in the game very quickly play isn't
that kind of interesting even Rugare
three is interesting now i come on let's
just let's just be ambitious for once if
it moves the rook night f5 should be
very nice compensation it might take on
age six but this is not something that i
mind at all okay so i'm going to take
him and go night at five this this is
just a bit better for for black i guess
s the default point is a week maybe 95
though maybe this is this is the thing
alright it's not a big deal right I
wonder if night f5 I think I should call
95 directly attacking d 4 i'm attacking
default and i also have the screen age
40 page eight IDM
that looks already a bit difficult for
me for white maybe you can somehow give
up the deep on and yeah this is possible
for Queen em I come on 496 okay rook to
e1 is also part of part of this let's
say home how to do that you really have
six maybe threaten snow threatens night
h4 maybe okay let's do it
I wonder if he goes nuclear one what I'm
doing then night h4 is threatening 25
but this is such a he can go Graham King
of 196 is not a threat / same rookie six
maybe years
rookie 16 ni de truck EF one that
doesn't really do much
okay success there no hmm I don't see a
good roof yeah it's kind of kind of
weird look if a does 96's this is
annoying and again after night after
night h4 I don't see a move okay they
have to play something I mean that
already took far too long
okay six I thought I can maybe just take
take you for work is six group g6 check
King h8 mmm no it's not no I don't know
is that the mate looks very very very
dangerous well I just had to play a move
I mean rookie 6i can also play Queen g7
this is not maybe not that terrible the
idea is to play rook to da it and it's
the move that I prepare here all night
XD for maybe without having to worry
about 2496 business so rookie Sixfields
very normal I think I got 27 done
okay at least he's taking his time as
well so timewise I'm catching up a
little bit him
white forfeits due to disconnection oh
wow I was really wondering a bit about
the long thing but okay I guess that's
that's rather lucky i mean the position
i have no idea about it looked very very
unclear to me okay this this was an
interesting idea Oh interesting either
computer wants to play Queen f8 just
keep age six and play form for
compensation all right now it's very
interesting oh this is a tag this is
attacked and kingi to this coming it
actually would have been already queen
fi queen f8 great move also this is this
very nice nope I was just thinking about
this now here yeah I can also go to d
fire but yeah King ga ta was interesting
and now the engine wants to play wants
to play Knight a choice it's completely
fearless yeah king of Warner and then I
didn't see a move this was my thing the
computer just wants to take this this is
something that I simply did not dare to
do jack maybe I'm just ok M the engine
gives 0 0 0 which is probably a
perpetual given the position here you
can trust the computer one hundred
percent on most of it if it gives you as
user it's a perpetual okay so this is
what I should have done then probably
okay this was kind of I don't know what
you do move now and now you're
disconnected yeah Ruby sixes the engines
main move after which you have to play q
in g7 this is probably happen somehow
lost but it's funny I computer gives
Quincy two words not very intuitive
what's also kind of afraid he would
check me here then
this okay this is just a petrol Queen
you to Widow is winning tending this
this well okay so i had to do this as
plan and now it's the computer gives
Queen to before nice move from night if
I grab here the Duke 37 so cannot do
that tough I'm under pressure engine
gets light a slight edge okay slider
channel 0.9 look f8f one it's very
difficult i mean those those moves are
somewhat computer issue i despair them
but i think in the in the actual game we
never know what happens and many
probably many mistakes from both sides
okay thanks for watching